I'm in aberdeenshire enjoying a dram of
peated whiskey
because that ingredient peat is on the
front line of our battle against climate
change we'll be telling you what it is
and why this key component of the Water
of Life could be under threat
so good
[Music]
welcome to the climate show with me Tom
Heap and this week we're all about Pete
something that should be our Ally in the
fight against climate change but all too
often is becoming an enemy now you can't
see it but it's surrounding me here
beneath my feet it's made up largely of
this sphagnum Moss which dwells in this
kind of wet Marsh and over centuries it
gets compressed and squeezed down and
turns into something pretty solid like
that the problem is this stuff is so
useful and is very widely commercially
exploited from the Smoky flavor of
famous peated whiskeys to much of our
most fertile Farmland the compost you
use in your garden or allotment and even
the deliberate burning of Heather on
peatlands for shooting grouse
this is Pete the compressed remains of
Marshall and plants it's a great soil
for crops a great compost for garden
plants and this lot is going off to
flavor whiskey but there's so much
concern about its climate impact the
governments are thinking of banning its
use not least here in Scotland
foreign
[Music]
heat covers roughly a tenth of the UK
and one-fifth of Scotland
[Music]
it is our biggest natural carbon store
holding more than the combined forests
of the UK France and Germany
it should look something like this the
exotically named red moss of Bolano just
outside Edinburgh heat is essentially
preserved Moss
and it's this Moss which is
and we've got an accumulation here of
thousands of years of sphagnum moss
that's got this amazing ability to
retain water
the problem is that it's proved so
useful away from the bog we grow food
with it
make a drink with it even heat some
homes with it but now we know the best
thing for us is to leave it well alone
it should be should be left in the
ground because it's a store of carbon
when it's damaged and degraded it
releases carbon into the atmosphere but
four-fifths of Scotland's peat is
degraded to some degree here it's being
dug and dried for fuel the moment it's
exposed to the air the key carbon lock
is broken when natural things like trees
or leaves rot decompose that's when they
give off their carbon into the
atmosphere and this shows you how it
doesn't really happen in peat this log
here is reckoned to be about 3
000 years old it's been down there that
long without decomposing until recently
when it became exposed to the atmosphere
that's the same problem with Pete it's
now turning into carbon dioxide
one third of the peat from here is
bought to warm homes the rest including
this load goes to dry malted barley for
whiskey so the business has been going
since 1905 and it's a family-owned
business we're now in the fourth
generation
um and how much do you take from here
it's about six thousand tons a year that
we produce
um three thousand for malting and three
thousand for fuel
and sales for domestic heating have been
brisk since the war in Ukraine made gas
and electricity so expensive
but it does have an outsized climate
impact for each Snug House in terms of
climate change is this not a bit like
cutting down the rainforest
it's an awful lot smaller scale than
cutting down the rainforest and there's
two million hectares of peat in Scotland
and we're harvesting from 80 hectares so
it's an absolutely minute area that
we're that we're actually harvesting
from
so rainforest sounds like total
Destruction and I don't think that's
what we're doing here
whiskey is Scotland's biggest export and
employs around 11 000 people especially
in rural areas Pete Kilns are vital for
many brands for that much loved PT reek
so we've now got our pitted warts from
the marshtime Tom about 60 000 liters
and we're now going to ferment it with
yeast into pitted beer I'll take about
three days and then I'll be ready to
distill it's just sensory overloading
let's place the site the smell there's
like a Magical Mystery to it yeah for
the nose if you want to step up here
there are four stages to making whiskey
molting mashing fermentation and finally
distillation this is where the magic
happens the still house oh you're
keeping me in suspense this Distillery
makes nearly 700 000 bottles of Ardmore
and provides the fingerprint malt
ingredient for one and a half million
more
for Our Brands and many others peat is
fundamentally important it creates that
unique character and flavor that our
consumers love
so how would a peat ban affect the
business
a unique and detrimental impact on what
is really Earth's you know flag waving
Standard Bearing export Scotch whiskey
such a hugely important export not just
to Scotland but to the UK as a whole
but here the whiskey industry are
funding the restoration of Pete bogg the
water from this one feeds The Distillery
below it's all about the wet watch
yourself yes there's plenty of water
around this bog had been drained and
invaded by trees so that the point of
this generally is to actually hold more
water here so the swag them can actually
grow because what we're looking for is
actual sphagnum growth the sphagnum is
the one of the main things which makes
peat and so by keeping a consistent
water table here that's what look at the
conditions that smegma need to grow
re-wetting like this spreads out the
Moss and allows the peat to build up
adding about one millimeter per year
that could have a big impact if
widespread
working with businesses there's a a
bigger opportunity because government
alone can't do this and it's really
important that all businesses businesses
use peat but also businesses that in
some way are using the natural
environment give something back this is
what we've seen out there on the peat
bog does it in effect offset the damage
that you're doing elsewhere yeah we tend
not to use a word offset what we're
looking to do is we replenish what we've
removed why is it you don't like offset
it has there's a lot of connotations
about things like green washing you know
people saying things are maybe not quite
as robust but as I say there's lots of
benefits to people in restoration
there's all the things about carbon
sequestration stopping the emissions of
carbon from degraded peatlands we're not
even talking carbon we're just purely
putting back more slag no Moss to
replenish the peat that we take out
whiskey is responsible for less than one
percent of peat extraction in Scotland
but that extraction remains an
industrial cause of climate change
should its iconic status get it off the
hook
so is a PT dram safe in the Scottish
government's hands well I'm going to
have a word with them about that and
other uses of Pete and I'm joined by
Murray McAllen who's the Scottish
environment Minister Mari why do you
think it's so important to tackle Pete
hard
well because becoming in a climate and a
knitted emergency
that Scotland's got some really
stretching climate targets to be Net
Zero by 2045 to get there via just
transition and Pete is a really
important nature-based solution
um as we seek to build that just
transition well let's look at some of
those different sectors let's start with
gardening what's your plan there
I've recently launched a consultation I
want industry Horticulture industry to
respond I want them to tell me about the
time scales over which they think they
can stop this well England's been very
clear on its time scale it says no no
Garden use by 2024 your own Royal
Botanical Garden in Edinburgh has said
gardening use needs to be seriously
challenged you need to get in and put a
date in there don't you to show you
serious
I need to do that once I'm in receipt or
views from people who'll be affected by
it so you know I want to make policy
that's what just transitions about it's
about taking people with you so I'm
asking all of the questions about the
outcomes and the time skills and then we
will uh we will consider all of that and
we'll stay at the deep but my objective
is ending the sale retail first
um and professional thereafter and then
considering other sales what about
whiskey should we continue to use Pete
for making whiskey well I think we to be
proportionate so we need to recognize
going into this that the vast majority
of uses of Pete is for Horticulture and
that's why that's right front and center
of the consultation comparatively
whiskey is a very a very small
percentage so I'm seeking their views
about how
um how any progression in this regard
would um affect them and also speaking
to the Scottish whiskey industry I know
that they are mindful of their use of
peaked and I know that they want to for
example do things like make sure that
they're restoring and absolutely getting
maximum efficiency of their uses of it
but what do you think yourself do you
think you want to see Pete continued in
whiskey or do you want to see it ended
if I can give you one example we've just
passed a seminal piece of planning
legislation in Scotland National
planning framework four and it took a
very hard line on the commercial
extraction of Pete seeing it won't
happen and there won't be allowance for
any extension but there was an exemption
to that which was for the Scottish
whiskey industry where it could be
demonstrated that they were restoring it
it seems to me that a ban on Pete and
whiskey is vanishingly unlikely am I
right
it's about proportionality and it's
about recognizing that the percentage of
P extracted for the use of whiskey is
comparatively very small what about
cutting and selling for burning for
keeping people warm in their homes
yeah so that needs to be considered it's
a very culturally important issue
particularly in Island communities and I
have a question in my consultation which
specifically asks about that again so
that I can harness as much information
as I can and make the theorist and and
most just decision so will Pete be
banned from the hearths of Scotland the
question is is it sold that's the first
question we're asking
okay so will it be banned for sale for
the hearths of Scotland
well as you heard from Maori the
Scottish government is looking to ban
Pete for gardeners but is reluctant to
put a date on it in England they've said
2024.
let's have a look at Wales where
Stephanie Haverty has been offering
advice on social media on how you Garden
without Pete
hello my name is Stephanie hafferty and
I grow as much food as I can year round
on my Homestead of about half an acre
here on a hillside in West Wales and
everything I grow from the smallest
seedling to trees in pots all of it is
grown using peak-free compost
[Music]
I'm an organic Gardener I grow with the
environment and wildlife in mind that's
as important to me as producing as much
food as I can
it would be really crazy to
do things to help wildlife and then buy
compost which harms wildlife and our
planet
Pete is an incredible carbon catcher
millions of tons of carbon are stored in
our peat box and when you dig a peat bog
to extract the peat that carbon is
released in the environment
foreign
it's one of the largest raised peat box
in the UK
even though it looks quite Bleak in the
winter time
coming to a landscape like this really
makes you realize the importance of
keeping Pete in the ground the peat
should be here for all of Nature and
everyone to enjoy and also for the vital
role it plays in our environment and the
health of our planet
Stephanie hafty with some gardening tips
one thing I've noticed near me is it's
often difficult to tell in the garden
centers which is the peat-free compost
and which is repeated labeling Clarity
could definitely be improved
now much of the peatland in England is
in the pennines where at this time of
year gamekeepers are often burning off
the Heather because those are lands
managed for shooting and the young
Grouse like to nibble on young Heather
buds many conservationists say this
damages Pete but some of the Moorland
managers say if done correctly it's good
for nature and it doesn't harm the peat
hi I'm Luke Steele and I'm the executive
director of wild Moors we're campaigning
to restore the Upland habitats and
peatlands which This Grass Moor is
currently sat on
bring with them huge environmental costs
particularly for peatlands which they
sit on
the peak Moors are regularly burnt to
drive through the younger fresher
Heather shoots for red grouse to eat the
idea being the more Heather there is the
more Grouse are available to be shot for
sports when the season arrives in August
but this brings with it many problems it
heavily degrades the peelings meaning
that they turn from massive carbon
stores into carbon emitters
and we've already recorded over 600
fires on moorlands like this one across
Northern England alone
[Music]
we all agreed that keeping carbon locked
in the soil is Paramount the latest
research shows that in the medium to
long term
careful vegetation burning is actually
good for capturing carbon in the soil
the fire service and government say
burning vegetation not peaked can be an
essential tool when done carefully by
trained and skilled individuals it's
useful for both conservation and helping
to control devastating wildfires that
take out vast areas of Moorland and
release frightening amounts of carbon
dioxide into the atmosphere
[Music]
we're also calling for that partial ban
to be extended to shallow peatlands
which are the most heavily degraded
peelans which urgently need our
attention to restore them back to that
healthier fitter state
foreign
we'll learn why the National Grid has
been spending hundreds of millions of
pounds switching off wind turbines and
we'll hear why this Barrister has been
evading police up a tree in
northamptonshire
[Music]
welcome back to the show and as you can
see I'm joined by our climate and energy
correspondent Hannah Thomas Peter Hannah
you've been looking at wind today and
particularly what happens when the wind
blows hard yeah we talk a lot about what
happens when the wind doesn't blow we
had to burn fossil fuels to fill the Gap
but actually we've got a bit of a
problem at the moment in the UK when
there's too much wind all of those
turbines up in the north in Scotland
North Sea they essentially produce too
much electricity for our grid to be able
to handle and so there's a real
bottleneck in the transmission systems
between Scotland and England and what
the National Grid has to do it's got no
choice it has to call up those wind
farms and say please turn off your
turbines and here's actually quite a lot
of money for doing so last year was
about 200 million quid now the logic of
that seems a bit perplexing at first but
I guess the the turbine people say look
we could be making money the wind is
blowing we could be spinning here and
it's you that's telling us we're not
allowed to send it away so you have to
compensate that's basically it so we pay
in the first instance to the wind
turbines to guarantee the amount of
electric see they pledge to give us then
we pay them to turn it off when they're
doing too much electricity for our
cables to handle and then here's the rub
we pay again to gas power stations
nearer to the source of demand often in
the south of the country to turn on to
fill the Gap because we still need that
power so it's all about the necessity of
upgrading the grid and the Renewables
industry has been saying for a long time
now we've got to do more is this a sort
of unfair Advantage for Renewables that
they get lots of Bill pays money or
taxpayers money to do this well Bill
payers do pay for all of this it gets
passed on directly to us once the
National Grid has shelled out the cash
in the first instance up front it then
goes on to our bills in the form of
network costs and we know that National
Grid has already said actually it's
probably going to get worse as we get
more and more wind power before the
infrastructure which is planned comes on
stream later in the decade but are these
kind of payments unique to Renewables no
the National Grid pays all kinds of
generators to ramp up and down fossil
fuels included but obviously there's
been a focus on wind because it is such
a critical part of our clean power
system we're supposed to be decarbonized
in terms of power generation by 2035.
now a few weeks ago we looked at the
issue of energy storage which as I
understand it helps to address this
problem because if you can store more of
that excess energy you're less likely to
melt the wires and you can use it later
on so batteries and other storage helps
such a critical part of the solving this
issue the UK is making leaps arguably
not fast enough the Renewables industry
has said we need to go much further much
faster if we're going to provide these
50 gigawatts of wind power by the end of
the decade insofar as there's a fault
here is is The Fault With The the wind
turbines the people generating
electricity or with the grid this is not
about wind being bad you know wind in
the UK is a success story and it's an
increasingly important part of our clean
power generation future this is about
frankly the rest of the country the
infrastructure the storage capacity
green hydrogen production even keeping
up with what's happening in terms of
wind generation there's been some news
this week as well from the government
having predicting a bright new future a
cheap new future for electricity yeah
Grant shops the Secretary of State for
the newly created department for energy
security and Net Zero Destin's although
apparently we're not allowed to say that
sounds like a sneeze
um he's been saying we want the UK to
have the cheapest hotel electricity
prices in Europe by 2035 and we're going
to do that by massively ramping up
Renewables and nuclear so it's that
combination that's the kind of green
future where where we're Galloping
towards according to new secretary of
state Galloping for 12 years off there's
not so much Jam tomorrow it was jamming
quite a few years just a quick one it's
been a very very dry February is this
going to have implications possibly
later in the year well we know it is the
driest February for 30 years or so
reservoirs just not filling up and we
could find ourselves back in Cornwall
talking about drought emergencies yeah
we could be on those dry lake beds once
again Hannah thank you very much indeed
now Barrister Paul Polson went viral on
social media this week after he evaded
police and climbed an old lime tree in
Wellingborough we caught up with him to
ask why he did it
all of these trees are protected by tree
preservation order TPO
um because they are an incredible
Heritage asset you know they're one of
the longest Avenues of lime trees in the
country they're over 100 years old
they're really beautiful they're one of
the key features of the Town 60 trees at
risk I think about 20 have been taken so
far ordinarily to fail a tree with a TPO
on it would be a criminal offense nobody
the council or the developer has shown
to local people that the necessary parts
of establishing the exemption actually
apply in this case and I began offering
advice and eventually wrote the legal
advice on Sunday night
um and when that didn't have any effect
on the developer or the council I
decided to go down to the site to try
and speak to the developer and the
police myself unless an exemption
applies topping down these trees is not
lawful have you spoke to the protesters
worked out what was going on and what
the kind of reasoning of the developer
was as far as I could tell it in that
instance I was faced with a choice I
could either just Koto to what I thought
was the police is wrong uh
interpretation of the law or I could
take peaceful positive action right
there and then to do something and
that's why I climbed into the tree I
didn't I wasn't I didn't plan to I
didn't have any food or water or warm
particularly warm clothing with me
and then I stayed there until I think
seven in the evening
um by which point I was getting
seriously cold and uh but luckily the
felling had stopped for that day so I
was under arrest throughout all of
yesterday but they couldn't put me into
custody because I was up a tree it's
quite funny and then eventually I made
an agreement with them that if I came
down and they
um didn't take me to the police stations
and I would come down I just don't think
I'm guilty of anything
um they've also given me a hilarious
bail condition that I'm not allowed to
climb any Tree in northamptonshire it's
really important that local tree
protectors get to see those plans and
say well and a question given the
importance of these trees to local
people I don't think that's unreasonable
unsurprisingly this has caused An
Almighty row with a developer Stanton
cross telling us that it is acting fully
within the law that the planning
permission overrides the preservation
order on the trees and that the
development will include the planting of
hundreds of new trees that's North
northamptonshire council's View as well
now before we go just a reminder that
you can catch the daily climate show at
3 30 p.m on weekdays on Sky News
and you can get all the latest climate
and environmental news on the Sky News
website or app by scanning the QR code
on your screen right now
but that's it from this week here in
Scotland we'll be back next week
assuming I don't take up residence as a
bog dweller see you then
[Music]